hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast best practices in
optimizing sample processing for improve
improved
flow cytometry presented by Chris spring
and Rebecca McHugh I'm Christina jewel
of lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab route the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning today's webinar is sponsored by
Milton E biotech the Milton u biotech
mission is to improve scientific
understanding and medical progress by
providing products and services that
advance biomedical research and cellular
therapy honoring this mission drives
their commitment to support the
translation of basic research into
therapy in areas of human immunology
cancer neuroscience and stem cell
biology for more information please go
to wwl-tv biotech comm now before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into that box that appears on
the screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or you can
use the Q&A button to let us know you're
having a problem this educational
webinar this is an educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the see e button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce our host mr. Cole
Jones product manager at the Milton E
biotech and sandy
California I will now turn the
presentation over to Cole Joan cool
thank you Christina so it's a pleasure
to be here today you know Christina
before we begin I want to make sure that
we can see the slides I can't see them
on my end so before we begin I'd like to
thank everyone for joining the webinar
as Christina mentioned will be
discussing latina biotechs best
practices in sample processing for
improved flow cytometry and our speakers
Chris spring and Rebecca McHugh will
share some examples and considerations
with respect to implementing these best
practices Chris greens is a flow
cytometry core specialist at the Kenan
Research Center for biomedical sciences
at st. Michael's Research Hospital in
Toronto Canada given his unique role and
it's listed as within a flow cytometry
core Chris will be speaking about the
key benefits of incorporating the
attendee biotechs techniques and
technologies into a flow core that
supports multiple labs and projects
Chris thank you for joining us today
Rebecca is Milton a biotech science
training manager in San Diego California
where she offers a number of hands-on
training courses ranging from general
topics such as flow cytometry basics and
foundations for cellular experiments to
more specialized training topics such as
max quant training and engine specific T
cell analysis training given her role
within science training Rebecca will be
highlighting some of the best practices
in sample preparation and present some
key considerations to think about when
applying closed otama tree analysis to
cellular experiments so thank you for
joining us today Rebecca to begin
addressing to begin addressing Milton
you biotechs best practices in sample
preparation first I'd like to highlight
a few of the general workflow items on
which we'll be focusing the work flows
includes three main steps tissue
dissociation sample preparation and flow
cytometry traditionally tissue
dissociation consisted of extracting
tissue samples followed by a manual
segregation as well as incubation with
incubation of the tissue with homemade
it with a homemade enzyme cocktail
typically the investigator chooses an
enzyme or set of enzymes based on
previous publication and then titrate
set enzyme for optimal performance this
can take a considerable amount of time
and once that single cell suspension is
produced direct cell separation or
isolation of the desired population is
produced and the selected cells is
analyzed in a flow cytometer but how
does this process work
when analyzing less frequent our rare
populations the rest of the webinar will
address this question and highlight how
modern methods for incorporating Milt
Indy biotechs instrumentation such as
our gentle max dissociate er are
automatics cell separator and our Max
cuantos odometer and how these
instruments will optimize the
standardized sample processing for
improved flow cytometry now Chris since
you're working with these instruments in
your flow core can you tell us more
about how these devices have audiences
your services that you provide for a
float for a flow core facility sure
thanks cool um so just to give you a
little bit of context the flow facility
that I run has a series of pieces of
infrastructure so we largely have some
photometers as well as cell sorter but
we also have a series of pieces of
infrastructure for upstream and
downstream cell biological applications
and we do have a whole slew of different
users looking at very different things
one of the things that we have is you've
alluded to the gentle max and that sort
of allowed us to do a better methodology
in terms of tissue dissociation so we
typically have lungs and spleen for the
most part coming through the facility
and as you'd mentioned lots of folks
will go out there and do a very old
manual preparation of these cells to
dissociate them and bring them into the
facilities so that usually involves
surgical isolation of the tissue in
question accrued homogenizing by mincing
or pushing saline stir mash etcetera and
end or a dissolution of the tissue into
we'll sell suspension through a cocktail
of enzymes DNA is EDTA cetera what I
find is that most of the time people do
this based on publications that are
older they're questionable there's
limited sort of in-depth in terms of
what they describe the user then goes
through and filters these samples to
remove undissociated pieces and then
they proceed to stain and perform flow
cytometry or other cellular analyses now
what we've found is that by including
the gentle max dissociate ER and the
core facility and the use of the SI
tubes which generate single-cell
suspensions and in my sister corps
upstairs we have folks using em tubes to
generate a molecular homogenous for
genomic analysis it's sort of a high
level population analysis as opposed to
sort of a single-cell transcriptomic
analysis that you'd get out of say a
fluid i'm c1 but those those systems go
off to the genomics core I typically see
single-cell suspensions coming to the
flow core and what we found is that this
really enhances the workflow that folks
have I've had people do old manual style
dissociation and by comparison when they
transit to an optimized cocktail based
kit solution that they typically
purchase from Milton II and then used
the gentlemen extracellular dissociate
or organ dissociation they get much
better yield of their cell populations
of interest viability from batch to
batch is also very reproducible and
their basal cell populations are also
extremely reproducible which we find is
not the case with all the manual style
tissue dissociation people will
sometimes go with old manual style
dissociation because they think it's
going to be cheap and quick but the
reality is they often spend a lot more
time trying to optimize these things
because they take it straight out of the
materials and methods rather than
titrate these things themselves and
their waste a lot a sample and time and
money on all of their antibodies and and
they actually spend more money instead
of using a kit based so
so once the users of our facility
typically have a single cell suspension
from an organ of interest they can go to
do
flow cytometry on this sometimes those
cell populations are not particularly
abundant and there's a requirement to
enrich for a particular cell population
or some population this is something
that we as I mentioned have a fact-based
cell sorting system and electrostatic
droplet system in the facility however
not all sorts are made equal and they're
not all accomplishable by taking your
raw cell suspension and doing seda
metrics sort so what this has in the
past looked like is isolation of cells
however each so choose to do so
stain and then either wash or don't wash
those cells and then do a fax based cell
source however we do have sorts where
that like I mentioned that's not
accomplishable so you can use the auto
max which is a magnetic based system to
either enrich for a cell population of
interest or deplete and undesirable cell
population and what that does at least
in our context is that you can take
billions of cells and process them by
enrichment or depletion in a very very
short period of time in the order of 10
minutes it also effectively washes away
any unbound antibody should that be
something that's actually required for
your specific sort and then you can move
on to do cell sorting which we'll talk
about in detail a little bit later you
get very viable cells they're very pure
they aren't sitting around for long
periods of time and you get short sorts
which means that if you are doing
genomic analyses on these things that
their RNA species are actually quite
well preserved and another side effect
of this is that you if you're purifying
for some population a and you need a
negative control that has no cell
population in it
you actually get both fractions back so
you can use the cell depleted fraction
as a negative control which a lot of our
users which have adopted most transfer
experiments actually find quite helpful
so in the end again in the context of my
particular facilities
so often looking to then do flow
cytometry after they have the cell
population that they would like to
analyze and with most of our instruments
this looks like me coming in in the
morning and doing QC on the instruments
the users isolate the cells that they
need they then stain them hopefully they
have brought the appropriate controls
for compensation and fmos etc although
we all know that that's not always the
case they then do their flow cytometry
and are supposed to wash the machine in
a multi-user environment again that's
not always the case then they take their
data off and rege ate it and analyze it
and third pretty software as needed in
the context of the max quant that we
have in this facility there are several
steps where we've found this to be
simplified or enhanced in terms of
functionality the QC of the max quant is
incredibly easy you just barcode scan
the bottle put a drop in a tube anyone
can do it my users do do this it's not
something I allow them to do on other
instruments because they can mess with
laser delays and other things that are
relatively catastrophic there's also a
pre enrichment possibility within the
max con itself so for an example you
could have a magnetic cd34 antibody if
you wanted to analyze c34 positive cells
and plasma the magnet turns on purifies
those cells and then you basically
elutes those cells by turning the magnet
off and then running your actual flow
analysis on that pre enriched population
I have a lot of basic users who rely on
software to compensate their their
samples and the thing about other
instruments is that software often tells
you that it's done a good job but
there's no proof of principle the max
quant will give you an N by n matrix
show you that the compensation is
correct on your samples so you don't end
up running these things under bad comp
settings and find out you know six
months later that you've been doing it
all wrong from a multi-user environment
I particularly like that you literally
cannot walk you can't walk away and not
wash the cytometry because we do have
lazy users that
that the instrument when you shut it off
will wash itself with its own buffers it
has it's very resistant to clogging so
in terms of a cleanliness perspective in
a multi-user environment it is very very
useful if you run lots of plates 96-well
plates the mini sampler on the max
quantity is completely walk away you can
put your stuff on there leave it will
clean itself and shut itself down when
you're done and you can come back to
analyze data you can get away with very
small sample volumes there's no way I'd
ever put 20 microliters on say for Tessa
but you can easily do that on a max
quant because it's a syringe based
system as opposed to a constant pressure
system and again for simple needs for
simple users that don't need to say
mathematically model there's their data
the they often have the data analyzed as
they like when they acquire it and the
mqt file formats on the Mac squat allows
them to take it off open it up in
another program right click say and
analyze it for me and it comes up
exactly as they've seen it and they can
take that and pull outside into their
publication of their lab meeting
presentation so overall what we've found
in our facility is that the systems are
very automated they're a foolproof
they're user-friendly they have lots of
advantages in a multi-user environment
and that's had an impact both on the
core facility as well as the quality of
the data that folks are taking away from
the core well thank you Chris so having
discussed several of the benefits of
this new workflow I'd like to take a
look at a real world example so we
recently performed a demonstration of
this methodology for the flow core at
the Ontario Institute for cancer
research and here their ultimate goal
was to isolate cv 31 positive lung
endothelial cells from whole lung tissue
so to do this they needed to dissociate
mouse lung and then deplete cd45
positive leukocytes followed by
enriching for the CD 31 positive
endothelial cells from the CD 45
negative population and then analyze the
isolated indices
cells for purity and viability so they
wanted to evaluate our instruments as
well so we brought in the gentle max
octo dissociate er with heaters the auto
max pro separator and the next quantile
analyzer they use the gentle max and our
lung tissue dissociation kit to
disaggregate the mouse lung tissue and
they use the auto max pro separator for
both the cd45 positive lah leukocyte
depletion and the CD 31 positive in
adílio cell enrichment and the next
client was used for flow cytometer
analysis to then assess that viability
and purity of the isolated endothelial
cells so here's the results from this
demonstration the far left graph shows
all cells from The Associated mouse lung
in a forward and side scatter plot and
the center graph shows the sample after
depleting the cd45 positive leukocytes
here looking at side scatter over CD 45
and the far right graph shows the sample
after the CD 31 positive endothelial
cell enrichment from CD 45 negative
population and here looking at side
scatter over CD 31 and Chris since your
lab supports since your core supports
labs doing similar work
I was wondering how does this data
compare to what you've observed so we
actually had a group that did do a
similar kind of experiments and what
they were what they started with was
doing a manual dissociation of lung and
a man they were looking for b-cells and
then an activation marker of b-cells and
what we found it first was with manual
dissociation first of all the forward
and side scatter applauded to see on the
far left for the lung looked absolutely
atrocious I mean it was just all over
the place you could barely find a cell
population and discriminate it from
anything else in addition to that they
had serious changes in their baseline
b-cells from control tube one to control
tube two so they should be really quite
identical and that was not at all the
case so if you're looking for changes
from your control group to your disease
group to your treatment group and you
massive variation in your controls alone
you're just never going to be able to
find that so these folks did it change
to using the gentle max for dissociation
of their lung they had very consistent
viability and very consistent yield of
their basal B cell population and then
looking at those activation states
within their model system of disease was
actually very successful and were able
to go on to publish that and that was
just the simple change for dissociation
in the first place thank you Chris so it
sounds like that our reproducibility and
the cleaner data is definitely
advantageous here so having looked an
example of where the cell type of
interest is more of an abundance
prevalence Rebecca will review some
considerations for flow analysis of the
more rare cell populations Thank You
Cole and thank you Chris as well lab
route for having me join you today on
this webinar so what I would like to
take time right now is just to talk
about flow cytometry as an application
for detecting and characterizing a very
rare cell and when you do this there are
several things that you have to take
into consideration one of one of which
is you should use some bright staining
reagents for Chrome's as well as
antibodies to help pull away that
population as well as you can from the
background in addition to that having
high-quality reagents or reagents that
have high specificity low background
binding will aid in your ability to
detect that rare event from the
background population of course using a
flow cytometer that gives you a very low
carryover between samples will aid and
not kind of interfering with detection
of your rare event of course there's
many different controls to choose from
when you do flow cytometry and not all
of them are going to be helpful in your
assay but of course you do need to
choose the right control for your rare
cell analysis but what I really want to
focus on
today is the necessity of acquiring such
a large number of events from your total
sample just to give you some statistical
significance in your characterization of
the rare event so with that there's
always the age-old question how many
cells must I analyze and in all
actuality it depends it really depends
on the target cell that you're
interested in characterizing so there is
going to be a lot of stuff on the slide
and mainly it is there just for your
reference but I just want to talk about
a few statistical considerations when
looking at a rare event one of which is
if you are just trying to enumerate that
rare event there is an inherent error
just to counting so the error in
counting is the square root of the
number of events that you've counted so
if you take a look at these examples
I've written here if you're counting 100
events the error in that count is the
square root of 100 or 10 and then if you
translate that into a precision of that
count you have a 10% CV so as you
increase the number of events you count
your error actually does increase but
your precision of your count goes down
so the more events you count the more
precise your count will be beyond that
you can look at perhaps how reproducible
your your account or your method is and
with this you can think about the
statistical consideration of a
confidence interval so if you if you
would like to be 95% confident that what
you're looking at in general that means
that your measurement is going to fall
within two standard deviations of your
average of that measurement and again
the detail on this slide is mainly just
for your reference but I would like to
combine these two statistical
considerations on the next slide here
and detail for you this little charts
that I've put together so on this chart
it is a detailing for you the number of
events that you should count if you
would like to be 95% confident that
you're within a certain percentage of
what's truly there you know in your tube
or in your sample of interest so if you
would like to be 10 you know 95%
confident that you're within 10 percent
of the measured value then that means
that you have to acquire about 1,500 of
your target events now what if your
target event was something so incredibly
rare such as maybe one in a hundred
thousand events so that means to acquire
1,500 of your target you would now need
to acquire over a hundred and fifty
three million of your total cell sample
and that can be quite unreasonable and
all of these values that are detailed
here in the red boxes are generally
going to be not capable of a flow
cytometry require in one data file and
in even if it could it would be very
difficult to analyze a sample size that
large so why not consider enriching for
your target event and therefore
decreasing the number of events you
absolutely have to acquire on the flow
cytometry so with this I would like to
talk about using a pre enrichment
technique to analyze a rare event such
as an antigen specific T cell and the
frequency of these cells can be in a
large range and if you look at trying to
detect an antigen specific T cell that
maybe has never seen its antigen before
so a naive cell this can be incredibly
rare in the peripheral blood and even
those cells that might be reactive to
autoantigens would be quite rare so we
are going to use the technique of a
positive selection with our magnetic
micro
and in this technique we're actually
going to be looking at antigen specific
t-cells by their functional response and
up-regulating an activation marker CD
154 or better known as cd40 ligand so
upon activation seeing their antigen the
cells will up regulate CB 154 and we can
target that with a magnetic particle
tacet cell sample over our column and
magnet system and those CD 154 positive
cells that have reacted to that antigen
will be retained on the column you can
wash away or debulk getting rid of
nonreactive cells and then basically
concentrate your flow cytometry on your
antigen specific t-cells so in this next
slide we are starting here with an
unsimilar it's already gated on cd4
positive on lymphocytes and we are
looking at on the x-axis the CD 154 and
here before stimulation not much
expression of CD 154 after a six hour
incubation with in this instance bkv
viral peptides you can see that CD 154
gets up regulated and there's a very
small percentage here but pretty
reasonable to look at by a flow
cytometry and if we look within this
activated population you can see that
they are also functionally responding by
producing here interfering gamma we also
looked for a functional response of
il-10 but it doesn't appear that maybe
aisle 10 is a functional response to
this antigen now as mentioned we were
going to pre enrich our sample targeting
that CD 154 and so here is an example of
that enrichment and so we now have a
majority of the cd4 cells that we're
looking at are the ones expressing CD
154 and now as we look at the subsequent
cytokine production of course you can
still see and confirm that we have the
interferon gamma but now you can start
to see that there are a few cells within
this antigen reactive species that
perhaps are making aisle 10 so in
another example
also using another viral peptide here
EBV you can see after the simulation is
actually not much CD 154 expression so
perhaps this donor this is not
responding to EBV peptides but we did do
the enrichment as well for CD 154
expression and after the enrichment you
can see that there are some CD 154
positive cells and these are also
producing interfering gamma Thank You
Rebecca
so having reviewed some of the important
considerations when doing flow analysis
of rare subpopulations a Chris you've
done similar work involving analysis of
rare cells in your flow core
particularly with regards to pre
enrichment before rare cell analysis or
even sorting
would you mind elaborating on those
experiences sure so what I've done is in
my context what we've done is looking at
sorting cell populations that would
otherwise not be particularly feasible
in the context of facts based cell
sorting so I'll take you through the
model that lab was trying to do and what
they were doing before enrichment as
well as post enrichment and so the
client lab was isolating most
splenocytes dissociating that tissue
manually and then taking after the fact
after they did a sort of properly taking
that and enriching it properly on and
automax for the subset of the population
that they were interested in that
enriched for what they would parse of
what they would like and then did the
further selection on a fax based cell
sort system which gave them large
numbers of t-cells that they adoptive ly
transferred into mice to accomplish an
immunological model of disease they
transferred various populations made
their comparisons and were able to
publish their result now the problem is
that when they first attempted to do
this if you look at this so here we have
a
three positive population on the far
left graphed in the middle graph we have
a red basically cd8 T cell population
above that on the y-axis in gray we have
a fit C positive cd4 positive T cell
fraction and then a cd25 positive
fraction that spreads out to the right
now if you look at this from a cell sort
perspective this population is only
about 2% of your total events and if
we're going to sort this and try to get
to three four million cells in a
reasonably short period of time for dr.
transfer experiments it was something
that was really quite frankly unfeasible
the felt short times were far too long
and the cells following the sort were
they didn't look particularly good there
cd25 profiles started to become altered
and it was problematic so what I had
them do was used the automatics to pre
enrich their cd4 cells and this is
something like I mentioned earlier which
is very very quick they can put a
massive bulk amount of cells billions of
cells through the instrument in ten
minutes which you cannot do in a droplet
based sorting system they were then now
left with basically just cd4 positive T
cells going through the cell sorter and
now what you can see is that two percent
population of cd25 positive cells is now
almost nine percent of their population
and this makes a dramatic difference in
their total cells sort time and the
quality of cells that they got out the
other end essentially it took it from
something that was on accomplishable to
something that was really quite
manageable and you know we took these
cells after the fact and we did a purity
check and made sure that they were quite
pure as you can see there there is a
little bit of photo bleaching of the
cd25
but basically they had very good
populations that came out the other end
and they were able to do their adoptive
transfer experiments this was probably
about a two hour source instead of an H
or nine hours sort that just wasn't
feasible and another thing that I don't
have done on the slide for but we found
a lot of use for the automax
is in depletion as well so we've had
brain that we've depleted of myelin to
do successful sorts friend appeal
cells which is essentially not doable
when you do have all of the myelin
debris in your cell suspension so
speaking of this pre enrichment strategy
for you know both flow analysis and even
sorting in general you know there are
even some experiment experiments that
may require pre enrichment before cell
sorting on a particular population of
interest and we have some data from a
lab up at the Cleveland Clinic the lab
of dr. Jeremy rich and on which the pre
enrichment of bulk tumor cells before
isolation of the rare cancer stem cells
from a PDX tumor model were were
isolated and Rebecca I was wondering if
you could elaborate on some of the
experiment here and the data in terms of
how that pre enrichment strategy really
did improve those downstream cell
separation to ultimately be able to
analyze and work with those those rare
cancer stem cells sure thanks Cole so
yes I would like to just talk a little
bit about the collaboration that we had
done with this group whose goal was to
establish an orthotopic packaging system
for their glioblastoma patient derived
samples so their whole goal was to
dissociate these primary tumors that
they were receiving and ortho topically
inject these into mouths so meaning
actually grow them in the biologically
relevant tissue that they are from and
so they were having many challenges
trying to get this established one of
which was that implanting these into
that relevant tissue really resulted in
a lot of mouth cells infiltrating these
tumors
and so when they were harvesting these
tumors out they were having a really
difficult time dissociating the human
tumor cells from just the infiltrating
mouth cell and that required trying to
isolate them and general fact sorting
was taking several hours to do so it was
also requiring them to genetically
modify these primary tumors to express a
fluorescent protein just for their
identification so to help them overcome
some of these challenges always forget
this point just to give you a little bit
more detail on this again they were
trying to establish a model system where
they could grow this glioblastoma tumor
into the brain of the mice and in
general what happens is as that a tumor
stablish 'as within the brain tissue it
infiltrates a lot of the healthy brain
tissue which when you extract that tumor
out you are going to be harvesting a lot
of them out cells as well so to help
them with this we suggested one of our
kits which is called a mell cell
depletion kit which is a cocktail of
magnetic micro beads that will target
many of the types of mouse cells that
can infiltrate a tumor and athelia cells
stromal cells so forth but with this you
really need to ensure that when you
harvest and associate that tissue that
you are not using any enzymes that can
compromise the expression of the epitope
that we need to target and so with that
we recommended to use the tumor
dissociation kit human so what they had
been using previously was a cocktail of
enzymes that also affected some of the
antigens that they wanted to sort for as
well and this tumor dissociation could
help preserve all of those enzymes that
there were all of those epitopes that
they were wanting to target so here is
just an example of some of the data if
we look up
here at the upper left hand corner of
this slide this is the flow analysis
prior to any depletion of mouth cells so
just after dissociation of the tumor you
can see that the actual cells themselves
was less than 10% of the population of
this associated tumor and within those
cells you could see the tumor cells they
are expressing the GSP but there are
also some cells that are not expressing
the GSP and these are also just some
lingering mouth cells that were being
identified as well so after using the
mouth cell depletion kits you can see
here that the pretty much all of the
cells are the gfp positive tumor cells
you can see that this depletion also got
rid of the majority of the debris that
makes it really difficult to do flow
sorting as well and then on the right
hand side you can see that their end
result was really to subdivide these
tumor cells into the cancer stem cell
population identified by the marker
cd133 and so after doing this cleanup
with a mouse Oh depletion they could
easily sort for cd133 positive cells and
also use the cd133 negative cells as a
control for their RNA seek and you can
see that they got quite a number of
quality aligned reads in both of these
subpopulations so just to summarize a
little bit about their overall goal is
prior to incorporating some of the
solutions that we could offer they were
really struggling with trying to do a 60
my study in this orthotopic model and
utilizing the gentle max with the tumor
dissociation kit they were able to
dissociate the tumor sufficiently
preserve all the antigens necessary
including that cd133 so they didn't have
to do any post Association
culture for re-expression so that that
lessened the amount of time to actually
get the cells of interest for their
study by doing the mouse cell depletion
this enables them to more easily sort
these cells and and all actuality
enabled them not even have to
genetically modify them with GFP for
tumor cell identification beyond that by
the bulking the whole system using that
Mouse cell depletion
we went from several hours required for
the sorting of these cancer stem cells
to just you know 30 minutes per sample
and this then enable them to really
consider the ability to do the 60 mice
cohort study so thank you Rebecca and
taking a look at the advantages at each
step it was mentioned that incorporating
the genomics technology into the tissue
dissociation allowed for increased yield
viability reproducibility and even
epitope preservation which is clearly
important when subsequent downstream
antibody staining of key epitopes for
analysis or further cell selection is
required a Chris earlier you mentioned
that dissociation with the gentle Mac
system is easier to optimize and
troubleshoot can you discuss what that
optimization and troubleshooting process
might look like when more manual methods
are used sure yeah so the way that
actually looks like I mean so there's
there's what should be and there's what
is right so the reality is that folks
accessing a core facility should be
taking their enzymes and optimizing
these things and titrating and all of
that but the reality is we could do is
you get graduate students who come in
and they read a materials and methods
that's missing half of the information
they tried to employ that methodology
and get a single cell suspension and
then when it doesn't work they have no
idea what to do they really don't know
where to begin with optimizing the
protocol or what to titrate and how and
they often ignore things like Rebecca's
talked about where you don't just care
about getting single cells reproducibly
time and time again but in preserving
antigens that aren't as bright like
cd133 so really that's when people kind
of pull out their hair say I have no
idea what I'm going to do I have no idea
what to change to fix this and they
really do kind of switch over to using a
time-saving technique like gentle max
okay thank you then moving on to the
automatics Pro separator and with
regards to cell separation so there
seems to be a time-saving benefits here
also the effective wash of unbound
antibodies is important when moving into
those downstream assays that require a
subsequent antibody staining and being
able to use the depleted fraction as the
control is also going to be advantageous
for downstream analysis though a lot of
times investigators are concerned about
recovering impurity of selected cells
Rebecca could you describe how the
automatics Pro separator can address
this concern yeah sure um so what one of
the features I really like about the
automatics Pro separator is the ability
to choose different types of programs
and a lot of these programs will differ
in the controlled flow rate that goes
over the column and how our technology
works is all a compromise between the
ability to retain the cell on the column
that's magnetically labeled and the
ability to wash away your unwanted cells
and all of this is going to be a trade
off with the flow rate so you can choose
a really fast faster flow rate if you
want higher purity of the cells being
retained on the column so it's easier to
wash away the cells you don't want you
can slow down the flow rate if you're
really concerned about recovery so that
you can try and retain every single cell
that has a magnetic antibody on the
surface so there's a lot of flexibility
in using the automatics if your goal is
really to let's say flow sort for
another sub population you could use the
automatic row separator to enhance the
recovery of your one cell type of
interest and then you can go then to
flow sorting for the purity of those
subsets in a more easy fashion and as
for the next Quan analyzer Chris you
previously mentioned several benefits
such as automated startup and shutdown
auto calibration compensation automatic
clearing between samples and even auto
labeling but because you discuss in a
little more detail how these benefits or
any other factors or event are
advantageous from a multi-user facility
perspective sure I mean so the reality
is these these advantages are
advantageous to everybody there are
advantages to an individual lab be it
small or large but in a multi-user
facility they're absolutely critical I
mean if you have things like clogs or
people not washing the machine queue
seeing it improperly getting you know
compensation done improperly in a
multi-user environment where people
often share templates etc and have large
cells or sticky cells
it's basically life or death I mean it
makes huge differences in terms of the
accessibility of the equipment and the
results that come out of the facility
which then of course turns into whether
people are using your facility or not
something else that I didn't
particularly mention that's not
immediately obvious is that most saitama
ters have very large cases of buffer
that you're required to use for sheath
sets are expensive on shipping and
they're cumbersome and then people don't
fill up your instruments
whereas the max quant has these little
one and a half liter sheath boxes that
last just as long as your standard
twenty liters sheath box which again is
something very useful for a multi-user
facility because people will bring down
their one and a half liter bottle plug
it into the side of the max quant and
actually fill up the sheath so it really
comes down to the maintenance of the
equipment's the use of the equipment in
the data that's coming out of the
facility being improved by these types
of things well thank you Chris and thank
you Rebecca for reviewing some of these
best practices and tips and tricks in
optimizing sample processing for
improved flow cytometry I'd like to
thank everyone for attending this
webinar and if you're interested in more
information please feel free to use the
contact information below and I think
now it's time for some question and
answers yes thank you Chris Rebekah and
Kol for that informative presentation it
is now time for Q&A if you do have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click
the send button we will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for ok
let's get started with our Q&A
cool I think you Christina so Chris one
question that pops up is how how is QC
different between the max quant and non
Milton flow cytometry
sure so the way that typically looks is
of course a little bit instrument
dependent but most other instruments
involve going into a portion of the
software running reference beads and
establishing settings and performance of
the instrument itself usually in so if
we take the example of say BT because
they are a large market site ometer that
people are familiar with there's lots of
information within those areas that is
sensitive to folks that don't
particularly know what they're doing if
they haven't been well-trained as flow
cytometry so they can mess with
instrument configurations
unintentionally they can change laser
delays on intentionally area scaling
things like that more easily than they
can do within the analytical portion of
the program so it's something that core
facility people end up doing most of the
work on and it's not a big deal but when
you have a large number of instruments
it can be a little bit time-consuming
with the max quant really you just scan
a bottles barcode it tells you on the
screen to put a draw
put into the tube you put a droplet into
the tube and it does everything else for
you and then shows you the information
it also has a prompter on the screen
that tells you this was the last time it
was Q seed maybe you should to see it or
definitely you should QC it so it's it's
nice to kind of take that and offset
that on to users as well as the fact
that users then are able to see exactly
what's happening and when thank you
Chris and Rebecca we had a question come
in about what is the impact of the
microbeads on the cells okay so um in a
way this is somewhat of a difficult
question to answer but the house of
microbeads
and our column technology is designed is
for the least amount of impact on the
cells so that these themselves are
incredibly small only 50 nanometers in
size about the size of a virus and are
really just a CO precipitate of destron
and iron and so basically sugar and iron
and that's what cells use anyway now the
column technology that we have enables
such a high magnetic gradient that you
only have to add such a small amount of
this magnetism to the surface of the
cell to be able to be retained within
the column magnet system so combining
with the fact that the iron and sugar is
so incredibly small as well as we are
not adding a lot of that to the surface
it doesn't have a huge impact so this
surface area of these microbeads are not
large enough for cross-linking of
receptors and they are biodegradable so
you know depending on how the receptor
is degraded that is basically going to
be the same pathway that that micro bead
will be degraded as well
Thank You Rebecca and Chris we had a
question come in about with what
criteria is used to state that the RNA
quality is better preserved so in that
particular example if I'm remembering
correctly we had folks actually take
these samples to the genomics facility
on site and they did a bio analyzer run
and looked at the degradation of the RNA
to establish the fact that it was
impaired thank you Chris and Rebecca
kachou regarding the CD cert in the city
of 133 slides can you explain why the
cd133 was not preserved prior to the
gentle next Association system yeah so
what I believe the enzyme that they were
using prior to incorporating the human
tumor dissociation kit was actually
papain I believe that is a general
enzyme required for brain dissociation
and cd133 is actually sensitive to pain
so the tumor dissociation kit does not
use papain as an enzyme and therefore
the cd133 was preserved post human tumor
dissociation and contact with the
gentlemen Thank You Rebecca and we also
had a question come in about what tissue
types are compatible with the gentle max
and for this question there's a there's
a broad array of tissue types that are
compatible such as lung liver neonatal
heart adult brain your natal brain post
natal brain basically almost anything
other than bone other than bone some
other things would be spleen skin
umbilical cord and there's there's a
whole array of a whole array of them
now Rebecca we had a question come in
with regard to the max quant in terms of
how it might address concerns about
inter sample carryover yeah sure so the
fluidics of the max quant is actually
quite stringent in terms of washing
through the flow cell and we have
validated if you use our standard inter
sample washing mode a carryover of less
than 0.01 percent and that's pretty much
kind of at the reasonable determination
of or detectability of an event
carryover so in terms of comparison to
other systems out there it has one of
the best kind of stringencies in terms
of carryover inter sample I think you
Rebecca Rebecca did you also answer this
question here and regarding what is the
best practice to wash DMSO from thawed
frozen core blood samples when
performing a cd34
enumeration and viability testing so
personally I do not have experience with
this particular assay however I know we
work with several researchers that are
using cord blood and therefore cd34
isolation and enumeration so I could
certainly look through some of our
technical archives and see if we have
any kind of best practices for the post
thaw washing and perhaps send some of
those recommendations to you well thank
you Rebecca
so I think that might be all the
questions we have at the moment
christina was there anything you'd like
to say before ending the call or maybe I
mean if any other last questions come in
before we before we end we'd be happy to
take those as well yes absolutely and I
do believe that's all the time we have
for the Q&A I would like to thank both
Chris purring and Rebecca McHugh for
that informative presentation and cool
fit Jones thank you for hosting that I
am I would also like to thank Milton E
biotech for making today's educational
webinar possible before we go I do want
to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 30th 2017 there will
not be PDFs available but you can
preview and view the on-demand viewing
all the way to the next six months
through May 30th 2017 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now we
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon
goodbye